foreign
City Utah and talk to the great and
wonderful Jeremy what's up Jeremy what's
up John it's great to talk to you and
also with you how we doing man
well I'm doing all right uh a little
nervous talking to you in real life
don't be nervous man uh how can I help
brother what's up
okay so I'm gonna start with my question
um
so
well the other day I kind of had to turn
on the lights
and just kind of see where my life was
at and I realized that I was
utterly alone in spirit and in mind and
I try
getting on the dating scene and doing
dating and it just
it doesn't work out either on their end
or my end and I'm just trying to find
ways that I can love myself to where
I can be there and
um
and
be a part of the dating scene yeah I
don't I don't know how to best explain
it no I I get it I get it what what
happened usually those moments when we
take an inventory of our life as you
said we just turn the lights on
usually there's there's a thing that
happens
correct so I was sitting around and I
just I was feeling really just bummed
out and
I just decided to I was just like why
why am I so sad about
like the day going on and
and uh
I I had kind of uh I just don't like how
I'm feeling right now and then I had uh
I started having kind of a panic attack
and
after I was able to calm that down I was
able to take inventory and I'm just
I just realized that I'm just all alone
and you know I have I have community
but
I don't why why do you feel like you
can't tell that Community who you really
are
I don't know I've I've just I just
learned recently how to be vulnerable
because of your show to my own family
it's awesome yeah but sometimes
sometimes family is a double-edged sword
they're great and they also can be the
source of some of our challenges
especially from childhood even though
they didn't mean to and so
it's kind of sometimes it's going back
to the rattlesnake and saying hey
um just wanted you to know like I'm
recovering from how I used to bite me
all the time
and you have to put yourself back in
distance of getting bit by the same
rattlesnake again correct and
unfortunately
um a score of seven on the aces
and
um just recently I decided that after
listening to your show that I wasn't
going to be responsible for my parents
parents's emotion and I decided to
yeah it was a hard one and so I decided
to have a deep conversation with with my
mom you know she's still around and
that was hard and you know she took it
quite well but
this this is all just from
and I kind of noticed that I was having
kind of like
um
like uh
wanting to check out
but I'm not I'm not a danger to myself
but
I'm
I just keep I just keep thinking man if
this doesn't get any better
like what is it gonna be like what am I
gonna do yeah and so I got to the point
that I was like I I need to throw a hell
of Mary now yeah
so let me tell you let me tell you
brother you're you're way way you think
this is the fourth quarter you're not
even done the first half yet
you don't need to be throwing Hail Marys
yet
you had a game plan or you had a coach
with a game plan and that got your head
knocked off in the first quarter and
then you're like dude I'm not playing
for this coach anymore
and courageously like very very few
people
you sat down with the rattlesnake and
you said you're not biting me anymore
that's a dude that's incredible
what we don't do enough and I'll own
some of this man what I don't do enough
is let people know that when you do put
up a boundary
there is a feeling of silence and
isolation behind that boundary for a
minute
because it's new
it's scary because you're all by
yourself
yeah so it feels
you're not crazy and you're not broken
your body's actually going whoa where is
everybody
and
um you've heard me say on the shows your
body will will solve for equilibrium
you'll try to get back up sulfur
homeostasis I'm sorry it'll try to get
back to the way it was it will go find
another dysfunctional relationship where
somebody drags you around and makes you
responsible which is why you're probably
dating people that are so familiar and
fun and then really quickly they remind
you a lot of the crap you went through
as a kid
and then you're like I'm out of here and
then it just starts over again
because your body wants to solve for
what it knows even if what it knows is
killing you
or I'll find a reason why I shouldn't be
with them and
and you know why that is right you've
heard me talk about that
is because of insecurity no no that's
you trying to beat yourself up when you
say about insecurity it's because your
body put a GPS pin and getting too close
to somebody because the last time you
did that I got you got you hurt bad
yeah and it probably came from Mom and
Dad
and or a big chunk of it did or Mom and
Dad were stood by and let it happen or
they didn't show up when it did happen
all that stuff and so your body knows
hey those two aren't going to step in
nobody's gonna step in
and so once we cross a threshold to get
too close I'm sounding every alarm I got
because I gotta I gotta protect you
because you're you Jeremy are too
interested in hooking up with somebody
and connecting with somebody and getting
some long-term stability and I got to
Keep Us Alive so your brain sounds the
alarms you break up you move on or you
do something that's erratic or not you
you text somebody 400 times in one night
because you feel anxious about the way
y'all left right fair right fair and
then they were like whoa too much and
they break up with you and then you
self-sabot the whole thing right so yeah
for sure it's a matter of okay we put up
some boundaries
well the good news is me and my mom have
a great relationship awesome I love her
absolutely so it wasn't terrible but I
was
I was just always afraid to have that
conversation with her
absolutely absolutely
so
really what I want you to think of the
Season you're in
is
um
you just got picked up on a basketball
team and they saw how good you were as
an athlete you just don't know anything
about basketball
and they put you out on the court and
you can run and you can jump and you can
rebound every once in a while but your
shots look ridiculous
when you shoot you're not even close to
the hoop
and when they're like
go go play the four go play the four
down the block you're like I don't know
what that means right I don't have the
idea or they're like yeah just run a
simple motion and you're like I don't
know what that is
all it is is it has nothing to do with
your ability has nothing to do with your
um brains it has nothing to do with your
um
athletic prowess
you just gotta learn some new skills
that's it
and so it's going to be awkward and it's
going to be uncomfortable but it's going
to be going towards the right thing
yeah see what I'm saying yeah now here's
what I'm gonna challenge you on
I think you probably think and feel and
have lots of emotions
and in many ways those thoughts and
feelings and heavy emotions become
paralyzing
mm-hmm
and I want you to come up with
a note card worth of
things you will commit to doing on a
daily basis
I don't care how you feel I don't care
what you think I don't care what your
emotions feel like I don't care if your
feet feel like lead
I will do these things
yeah
and you're gonna have to act your way
into becoming
a person you are proud of
I'm proud as hell of you right now but
the what I feel about you doesn't matter
you've been chasing external validation
your whole life and you've realized at
this point it doesn't fill you up
doesn't work
and it's also in some parts hard to
believe that's right you know
because you know
that you didn't even exercise today
you know that you had some work
assignments I don't even do them today
you know
yeah and so the way I've heard it said
that I love is if you're looking for
somebody when someone says like Hey how
do I find somebody to date and connect
with
it sounds counter-intuitive but I want
you to be calm to focus on you with an
intensity of becoming the best version
of you
I'm gonna exercise I'm gonna sign up for
a local community college class to take
a course in Shakespeare or psychology or
theater I'm going to do something so out
of my wheelhouse but I'm gonna go every
class
yeah I'm gonna learn how to dance
and I've been to Salt Lake you all
cannot dance
right I I I'm gonna do these things
I'm gonna learn Spanish I am going to
learn wood cutting I'm going to do stuff
that I want to do that I love doing and
my promise to you Jeremy is as you grow
in
micro achievements little bitty like I
don't know how to play this song on
guitar and I'm gonna sit there and sit
there and sit there until I figure it
out and I'm gonna be able to play it and
I will walk two inches taller to go to
bed that night let me get up tomorrow
and do it again
yeah you spend so much time thinking and
thinking and thinking and thinking and
feeling and feeling and feeling and
thinking
and I want to give your body some like a
season of little wins
I'm gonna call a friend I'm gonna call a
friend I'm gonna call a friend and then
I'm not gonna text him when we get done
I'm gonna feel how awkward in that
little spinny I shouldn't have said this
I think it's funny
I have a buddy of mine I do have a buddy
of mine who I love
who we hang out and we hang out for a
while and then sends me long texts like
so sorry dude I was weird a little bit
awkward today and finally I called and I
was like you're never allowed to post
hangout text me ever again
like you're my friend of course you're
weird and you're my friend of course you
say dumb things I do too you're my
friend
you don't need to you're not you're not
at a job interview
you're my friend yeah right
you have to practice that
do you have three friends that you could
call right now
and invite him over for dinner this week
and say hey I've never told you guys
about my childhood and I talked to this
goofball on YouTube or on podcast
and he kept telling me that grief
Demands a witness so I just want to tell
you about some stuff that happened and I
know it's gonna be weird but
I trust y'all
do you have three people you could do
that with
oh that's so hard because bro I know I
know
that's the I'm open I'm an open book
it's just no you're not you are not you
know you have uh ripped out chapters one
through five out of your story I'm an
open book until you get to The First
beginning that's right you don't let
anybody read chapters one through five
you want to just pick you up after you
graduated college and look how fancy I
am
yeah and that's not your story man
okay your story is look at the hell I
endured and look who I've become on the
backside of this
yeah for sure that's your story
and the more you run from it
the the stronger it becomes
and when you're when you have friends
that You're vulnerable with when you
have
um somebody that you are dating and
you're and you're getting closer and
closer and closer to
they feel the secrets on you they just
don't know what it is and they think
it's their fault and it feels
uncomfortable and so it's easier to not
be in a relationship with those Secrets
I feel it right it's like being in a
dark room and you know there's like
someone's gonna jump out and grab you
you just don't know where it is you're
like dude I'm getting out of here yeah
it's that
yeah
and listen those three people
they could they could roast you with
your secrets no question
but they probably won't
or maybe get a counselor in practice
that's what I did I did it recently told
some hard hard stuff I had told zero
people
zero people
and then practicing with a counselor was
hard and healing
and then I told my wife and then I told
some friends
and it has a completely lost its power
over me
and see I wanted to go to counseling but
part of me a loud part of their
inside of me is just screaming what's
the point
you know let me tell you the point
how old are you brother
36 okay
I've got some years on you okay I'm in
my 40s now I'm an old man
I'll tell you the point
I laugh from my guts now
and I fall I fall asleep without meds
and I don't hardly ever drink anymore
because I don't need it to be close to
people
and
I have two knucklehead little kids that
I love more than life itself
and I have a wife that has been through
thick and thin and hell and back with me
and
um I just breathe easier when she's
around
oh that'd be that'd be a huge relief I
know but listen I only got there when I
started being honest
and I'm not talking about dishonest like
not cheating on you and not not that's
not what I mean
I mean when I started saying things like
hey I really want this or I need this
I'm scared about this
and she finally said oh sweet man now I
can now I can connect
but I had to go first
yeah
it seems like the
climbing up a mountain
I can't describe how perfect you're now
you just nailed it
there's a book by one of the most
extraordinary minds of Our Generation
his name is David Brooks and the book is
called the second Mountain I want you to
check that book out it's really really
powerful
um in fact it's real real powerful I
think you would I think you would really
benefit from it and hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of my brand new
book building a non-anxious life
and it's gonna it it is six choices and
it's a wheel and if any one of these
these choices gets out of whack the the
whole wheel wobbles and the car won't
drive the right way the bike won't won't
wobble will fall off right so hang on
the line I'm gonna send you a copy of
this thing I want you to go through it
start to finish so square one all the
way through
actually you know what I want you to um
pick up on your past change your future
too I know you've got a history with Ace
of score and it talks about the aces in
in that book too helping you walk
through some of these challenges but
listen
you are not at Hail Mary time
am I a 100 expectation is if you wake up
and you say I'm ready to check out I'm
ready to not be alive anymore that you
will call somebody
I've got your word on that
but we're way way off from that
right now you're a young man he's 36
years old you're not even at the second
half yet
and yeah you got banged up in the first
quarter first half you did you got beat
up pretty good
you're gonna go in the locker room and
regroup get some people around you
change the game plan get some new
strategies change up the Personnel get a
new coach or two or three
and then we're gonna go back out there
and you said what's it all for let me
tell you why I got two little kids that
need you
because you my brother are creating the
world that they're gonna live in
I need you
they need you your neighbors need you
that woman that you're going to meet and
fall deeply in love with will need you
those little knuckleheaded kids that
you're gonna have one day will need you
hang on the line brother I'm going to
send you some stuff and get you hooked
up
you call any time
and I'll walk with you
thank you so much for being brave man
like you you're the real deal Holyfield
Jeremy
got a long road to go but man
that light's bright on the other side